you're watching book TV on c-span 2 this
weekend we're visiting Las Vegas Nevada
to talk with local authors and toured
the city's literary sites with the help
of our local cable partner Cox
Communications next we discuss sun-sin
and suburbia an essential history of
modern Las Vegas with author Jeff
Schumacher
so when people think about Las Vegas
they typically think about the Las Vegas
Strip right I mean think about the big
casinos they think about the shows they
think about gambling - think about the
restaurants they might think about
downtown Las Vegas where we have the
older casinos and we have Fremont Street
with all of the spectacle of the
promenade so that's what I think people
immediately think of when someone who
lives here someone who writes about Las
Vegas I don't necessarily think of that
first I think about the people the two
million people who live here I think
about the neighborhoods where I live and
where my friends and relatives live and
so much more I think nuanced and
complicated story than the typical
person from outside of town
imagine Las Vegas has been growing ever
since 1905 when it was you know founded
as a railroad town however there's
certain times certain decades when
things really accelerated and one of
those was certainly the 1940s and the
1940s you saw with during World War two
you saw the arrival here of a huge
magnesium production plant and this
production plant drew thousands and
thousands of workers to Las Vegas then
at the same time you had the development
of an army airfield which later became
an Air Force Base again thousands and
thousands of people descending on this
valley trip you know quadrupling the
population in a matter of years
coinciding with that was the development
of the casino business on a much larger
scale and those casinos again drew
workers they drew tourists and Las Vegas
became a a tourist place so the 40s were
huge the 50s is when you saw the rise of
all the iconic casinos on the Las Vegas
Strip that coincided with the rise of
atomic testing 60 miles north of Las
Vegas and so again a lot of scientists a
lot of others who needed to work at the
atomic testing site came and lived in
lost came to live in Las Vegas again
tourists also came to Las Vegas just to
witness these spectacles these
above-ground atomic explosions and so
the 40s and 50s I would have to say
where this really pivotal time
for las vegas and its growth las vegas
faced at a lot of different challenges
as it grew so quickly one was
transportation one another was education
building enough schools to accommodate
all of these kids a transportation for
example the building of the airport i
mean we were very late in getting caught
up with the demand and so the
development of McCarran Airport it was
opened and then suddenly you're already
talking about expanding expanding
expanding and then in the 50s you saw
the need to develop roads and you needed
to develop the infrastructure for the
spreading of the city and you know we
were always behind the curve Las Vegas
has never ever quite kept up with the
growth and that's probably the nature of
all fast-growing cities in the West but
Las Vegas has had an extreme case Chris
Wall the positive side keeping up with
growth in Las Vegas means there's lots
of jobs there's lots of people needed we
need manpower I need people to work in
the casinos we need them to work on the
construction we need them to work in the
different businesses around the
community so I'll see people coming here
for opportunities when they get here
oftentimes in the past there have been
you know school overcrowding that's a
big problem you find that there aren't
enough amenities restaurants are crowded
for example you find that the roads are
insufficient so people are living on
gravel roads that should otherwise be
paved and you're just this and then most
importantly you don't have enough tax
dollars you know to pay for all of these
infrastructure needs that you have so
then you're starting to look at raising
taxes raising property taxes raising
sales taxes etc in order to be able to
afford all of these new amenities so
again Las Vegas is constantly trying to
keep up with its growth in it and it has
really never let up there's a lot of
people who've been around Las Vegas for
a long time who would like to keep that
small-town feel that they remember here
from the earlier days unfortunately Las
Vegas has always been in a growth mode
and it there's never been a real sincere
attempt to control or manage
in Las Vegas we just you know we're
opportunists right we're just constantly
looking for the next opportunity whether
it's developing subdivisions or
commercial areas or casinos and so the
impact of the growth of the strip on the
suburbs has been this sort of insatiable
demand for more housing and when you
have more housing then you need more
schools and need more parks you need
more roads and you know we're basically
one big construction site you know and
that's been going on for decades now in
the past Las Vegas has had recessions it
suffered from slowdowns in its growth
you know periodically those national
recessions there's other kinds of
challenges that come up we had a water
issue in the early 90s that slowed up
the development for a while
but what happened in 2007 and 2008 was
almost unprecedented for Las Vegas
because we saw you know the real estate
market collapse here so dramatically and
then we saw the national recession that
hit with the wall street color crisis
and it just hammered Las Vegas tourism
so at that point between Satan 2007 and
2012 or 13 Las Vegas was in very sorry
shape you saw a lot of homes foreclosed
upon we saw people losing their jobs
high unemployment rate and you saw a lot
of vacant buildings not just houses but
commercial buildings and Las Vegas took
a long time to recover from that the
damage to the foreclosed upon homes by
squatters the people who get upset
because they're being evicted and they
tear up the house you saw this again and
again and again here you saw a lot more
homeless people on the streets you saw
people leaving town because they needed
to go find work somewhere or they lost
their home in the construction industry
the unemployment rate here was 50% so I
mean this is an amazing number for a
town that where people have grown
literally rich working blue-collar
construction work so you know it was a
very severe recession and it hit Las
Vegas as hard or harder than any place
in the country
the good news is the positive side is
Las Vegas is pretty resilient and it is
fighting back it is coming back the
growth is returning the economy is
growing people are getting back to work
and by 2016 you know things are starting
to look bright so I think the biggest
takeaway from sunset in suburbia is that
this is a community that has many more
facets than simply the strip the book
deals with the strip we have the history
of this strip I have the history of
downtown in the book it's very important
it's the crux of the whole enterprise
here but the the point of this book is
to for people who are local to kind of
understand where they live a little
better and if you're not local to
understand that this is a more complex
and interesting place than simply the
rows of slot machines along Fremont
Street or a long Las Vegas Boulevard
for more information on book TVs recent
visit to Las Vegas and many other
destinations on our city's tour